a great director is somebody who can
take a talented bunch of people and crew
talented crew and a good script and turn
it into gold and that's what mr. Dona
does around the people he works with I
got a gift for him back there huh you
only just hold on one second okay is
this remind you of anybody huh somebody
sitting out there somebody sitting out
there
yeah the sweetest lion I've ever met
here you want to hold that for me now
sorry I tell you this is the kind of
stuff that when you feel this this
freedom of work it's frightening this
man has a spirit and an energy that
encourages everybody to do their best
brings out the best talented and
talented people I mean look at his films
my god every film I feel close to the
work that we did when I watch these
wonderful actors great people doing
their stories with a little bit of humor
and my sense of the work he brought that
to everybody and the pathos you know
compassion we don't have enough of those
movies today do it yeah and I think what
if face it dick Dodd did and does and I
think for all of us who've worked with
them and you know you said that he set a
bar he really does set a bar there's
been directors I've worked with and you
probably work there that come close but
they really haven't passed it and in
what he does is when he brings that
company together those actors in that
crew he creates a family and you know a
lot of you know we treat the with
respect
dick treats us all with affection and
really would love and when you use ances
what takes chances us you know we had a
great cinematographer who we loved
lászló kovács Hungarian
I have done a great film with a great
cinematographer called Dilma Sigmund
that is the story you may know but I
think it was difficult to always
remember character names people names is
hard for me and the cinematographer was
quiet he was kind of like more reserved
than Richard who has a voice that just
calls the attention of the people
getting on the bus two blocks away but
he couldn't only get the name right you
may know the story he would call for
vemos or vim [ __ ] or last Lazlo Lazlo and
get the names mixed up and he made
t-shirts with the names and switched
them when they almost came to visit so
nobody could remember the name of the
cinematographer but anyway we all took
chances he supported us no matter what
and God bless thank you yeah
[Laughter]